je me trouve au site de maintenance et
de remisage du thé 13 à versailles ce
tout nouveau tram train va relier saint
germes en lait à saint cyr l'école en 30
minutes et c'est ce mercredi 6 juillet
que sera mis en circulation ce tram
train nous allons vous faire découvrir
en avant-première ce tout nouveau moyen
de transport pour les aliments
[Musique]
ici on se trouve dans la cabine en 2d
d'un des conducteurs exacte cela alors
le thé 13 finalement ce sera un tram
train ce sens qu'ils peuvent expliquer
un peu qu'est ce que c'est alors en fait
le tram train c'est un mode de lure
ou on peut circuler à la fois sûre du
réseau de train est la façon de gérer
notre âme il faut savoir qu'il ya deux
types de rails donc il ya des règles
spécifiques au train et un réseau
spécifique aux autres âmes avec les
différentes vitesses j'imagine
exactement le la vitesse max en train
les 200 km/heure et la vitesse max entre
amal est de 70 km sachant qu'on peut
avoir des tables indicateurs de vitesse
qui volume illimité plus ou moins en
fonction des portions on va se trouver
qui peut être abaissé à 30 40 et vous en
tant que conducteur qu'est ce que ça
change concrètement alors du coup moins
tant que conducteur quand je suis sur la
part dix trains et j'ai des dispositifs
de sécurité que je ne veux pas forcément
retrouver en tram donc du coup j'ai des
dispositifs qui vont contrôler au
courant continu ma vitesse la
signalisation que je vais rencontrer
faut savoir que on a des dispositifs sur
la partie train qui permet de
transporter les voyageurs en toute
sécurité sur la partie trame du coup je
vais changer de mode je vais être
en vitesse et en mode de conduite est
pris dans des jours là c'est ça ouais
mais bon tout est rôdé tout est rôdé on
a fait nos essais on est prêt pour
lancement
se situe maintenant côté passager dans
la rame
combien de belges justement combien de
passagers accueillis recettes là on peut
accueillir 250 voyageurs à bord elle est
accessible à tous oui hélas elle est
assez accessibles aux pmr surtout on
faut savoir que le côté tram donc du
coup il ya une forte accessibilité pour
les pmr donc quand je dis pmr aussi bien
les personnes avec des poussettes
quand en fauteuil roulant ou des
personnes qui ont de deux gros charge à
porter des valises ou quoi que ce soit
qui ait un grand espace c'est ça donc du
coup il ya des voitures noonan espace
assez large pour qu'elle puisse rentrer
à bord de la rame et s'asseoir
tranquillement toute sécurité
alors oui et comment deux rames et ici
nous avons sur le parc au total onze
rames d'accord sur des services sur
plusieurs stations c'est ça on a douze
stations ont fait savoir que la ligne
fait à peu près 19 kilomètres pour un
temps de trajet de 30 minutes est ce
qu'il ya des spécificités ici dans cette
rame alors les spécificités on à
l'arrivée des prises usb pour les
voyageurs pour brancher leur chargeur ou
autre c'est très vite il a exactement
surtout qu'on n'a plus de batterie ou
qu'on peut travailler à bord du de la
rame du train tram train donc comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure en fait ce
qui change par rapport à un train
classique c'est que tout est à portée de
main donc du coup il a juste à appuyer
sur des boutons pour signaler sa
présence au conducteur donc le bleu ou
alors le bouton sos il a un problème et
donc du coup on a la chance aussi
d'avoir deux rames neuves silencieuse
est très très moderne oui oui c'est ça
les spécificités finalement c'est que
c'est un tram train bah finalement très
accessible ce sont efficaces et
performants et performant c'est très
bien elle va merci beaucoup
[Musique]